a
[Música]
la vida es un cúmulo de experiencias
positivas y negativas que van forjando
nuestro camino yo me considero una
muestra de todo ese proceso porque me
han influenciado
mis colegas mi familia mis amigos una
comunidad yo soy bernarda delgado elías
arqueóloga de profesión carrera que
elegí culmine gracias al apoyo de mis
padres de mi madre alicia díaz de
delgado y de mi padre alfredo josé
delgado grabó un poeta escritor y nada
menos que el autor del himno a la ciudad
de chiclayo y de monsefú mi tierra natal
por lo que es muy recordado hasta la
fecha
recuerdo claramente cuando fuimos con mi
papá a trujillo para inscribirme en la
universidad nacional en la carrera de
farmacia
y por esas cosas que tiene la vida que
tiene el destino mi papá enfermo en el
camino y no conseguimos llegar a tiempo
y no pude inscribirme en farmacia y lo
único que quedaba en ese momento era
arqueología
por lo tanto considerando que en el
colegio a mí me habían gustado siempre
tres materias la literatura la química y
la historia pues pensé que también
ayudada por mi papá que la arqueología
estaba bien para mí hubo algunos
momentos en que no me sentí muy a gusto
y quise dejar los estudios y fue mi
padre quien siempre alentando me y
apoyándome me ayudó a que continuara los
estudios y los culminar y durante todo
mi ejercicio profesional fueron mis
papás los que me dieron mucha fuerza
para seguir en este en este camino
y además me animaba mucho el orgullo que
yo sentía por los
éxitos alcanzados en ciertas en ciertos
momentos de este trabajo por supuesto
acompañada de una gran cantidad de
instituciones y de personas mis colegas
influenciaron en mí también de diferente
manera unos porque
no creyeron que yo era capaz de dirigir
una institución como el museo por el
simple hecho de ser mujer o por el
contrario otros que me invitaron a
participar del proyecto que los tucu me
como alfredo narváez quien es arqueólogo
y antropólogo a la vez y que nos enseñó
a trabajar con el pasado pero también
con la comunidad del presente lo más
interesante que tuvimos en ese en ese
tiempo en el proyecto fue que conocimos
a thor heyerdahl que fue todo un
privilegio para nosotros porque era una
personalidad y en ese tiempo una leyenda
viva y fue él quien organizó el proyecto
arqueológico y fue él quien
sembró la semillita del desarrollo
cultural en nuestro pueblo
la comunidad de túcume ha influenciado
en mí también de manera muy positiva
hasta la fecha la gente muy cariñosa
amable y respetuosa los paisajes los
algarrobos
sus cuentos sus mitos sus leyendas el
misticismo y la ciudad de las pirámides
influenció tanto en mí que hizo que me
quedara no los tres meses que yo había
pensado inicialmente sino ya estos
treinta y dos años para mí ser
arqueóloga ha sido realmente un reto en
mi vida porque en mis inicios en mis
prácticas preprofesionales
yo tenía un fuerte problema de salud
tenía una alergia que me impedía
trabajar con tierra y siempre estaba
llorando con una congestión nasal muy
fuerte que algunos de mis colegas
también burlándose de mí me decía que yo
no iba a culminar que no iba a terminar
mi carrera y que mejor me fuera a mi
casa
cosa que a mí en vez de desalentar me me
animó más
y terminé la carrera porque además era
una de las pasiones más grandes de mi
vida
escudriñar en el pasado y saber lo de
las lo que las sociedades pasadas habían
creado
pero luego también el factor género tuvo
mucho que ver porque a mí me revelaba
mucho el que dijeran que por ser
arqueóloga no podía hacer tal o cual
cosa y como no podía yo seguir en una
profesión que amaba tanto que me
permitía conocer y descubrir el pasado
continúe y ahora estoy
feliz y tranquila en un espacio que
en donde me siento acompañada y en donde
pensamos entre todos las personas que
estamos aquí que hemos conseguido cosas
por ese trabajo en equipo antes de venir
a tucumán
he participado en otros proyectos
arqueológicos como en cajamarca como en
amazonas en trujillo pero el venir el
estar en túcume ha significado realmente
una experiencia tan importante porque
hemos podido
intercambiar pensamientos
costumbres ideas especialmente con la
comunidad local que me ha acompañado
durante todo el trabajo y así como
investigamos en la ciudad de las
pirámides para descubrir lo que ellas
fueron o para qué fueron creadas también
compartíamos
desayunos almuerzos con la plana obrera
que en realidad era muy satisfactorio
para nosotros pasaron los años y el
proyecto tenía que culminar
en cinco años
pero el director del proyecto tuvo una
grandiosa idea y gestionó y consiguió la
construcción e implementación del museo
túcume en el año 1992 y el museo siguió
la línea ese trabajo de arqueología
comunitaria ese trabajo participativo
ese trabajo donde la gente podía no
solamente decir cosas sino proponer
cosas y además aprender era realmente
muy gratificante y el museo
estrechó los vínculos con la comunidad
de tal manera que se desarrollaron una
serie de proyectos que no solamente
tenían que ver con arqueología sino
tenían que ver también con la puesta en
valor para el uso social del patrimonio
tendrían que ver con la inserción
comunitaria y tenían que ver con
estos proyectos integrales para el
desarrollo sostenible de nuestra
comunidad
en el museo
dado que la participación comunitaria
era intensa
pensamos que ya era el momento adecuado
para formalizar este vínculo con la
comunidad y crear el ecomuseo túcume un
ecomuseo no es no viene de ecología l
como usted es una plataforma en donde la
gente se refleja en donde la gente ve
reflejada sus vivencias y su vida
cotidiana
después de estas de esta experiencia con
el museo de túcume con el ecomuseo de
túcume nosotros tenemos realmente una
una gran una buena cantidad de ejemplos
que nos están mostrando esta
transformación social que ha devenido a
partir de la gestión cultural del
patrimonio con participación ciudadana
por ejemplo
un grupo de niños que empezó con
nosotros como jugando a participar de la
clínica de arqueología y conservación
para niños y jóvenes que tenemos acá de
ese grupo que empezó con nosotros en el
año 98 hay varios jovencitos que ya
terminaron de estudiar la carrera ahora
tenemos a arqueólogos tucumanos por
primera vez pero además este tema de la
gestión del patrimonio ha ayudado que
los niños tengan otro lenguaje tengan
otra forma de expresarse respecto a su
patrimonio lo hablan con mayor propiedad
y lo defienden también con mucho orgullo
y con mucha pasión tenemos lideresas
locales como estrellitas burgos por
ejemplo que ahora es
concejal del municipio actual y también
tenemos a miluska
wimax que es arqueóloga pero actualmente
está trabajando con nosotros pero además
ya en el otro plano en el plano
artesanal ejemplos bien interesantes de
esta transformación social que acabo de
mencionar porque
susan avances que es una artesana
tejedora experta en telar de cintura
se ha posesionado de tal manera de su
oficio que ahora además enseña a las
nuevas generaciones y participa del
programa educativo activamente así como
el resto de los artesanos ya no son
solamente artesanos sino además son
profesores ellos participan o dictan
talleres
artesanales no solamente para la
comunidad local sino también para las
instituciones que solicitan su presencia
entonces tenemos allí tres ejemplos de
vida
de que ha sido
encaminada a partir de la gestión
cultural de encontrar una profesión a
fin de ser liderezas en su pueblo y de
trabajar como artesana procurando
beneficios para su familia también
estos este impacto social del patrimonio
tiene que ver entonces con lo personal
con lo profesional y con lo comunitario
porque recuerdo que en conjunto varias
instituciones del pueblo vale decir el
museo el municipio la parroquia los
grupos de danzantes
gestionaron que la danza de los
diablicos de túcume fuera considerada
como patrimonio cultural de la nación y
en el 2013 lo conseguimos un trabajo en
equipo un trabajo mancomunado que ahora
le da muchísima fortaleza a esta danza
antes habían 100 niños o jóvenes
danzantes ahora hay más de 500 jóvenes
danzantes entre hombres y mujeres que
acompañan a nuestra virgen de la
purísima concepción en su fiesta
patronal
entonces todo este esta historia que les
acabo de contar es una historia que
tiene que ver con la museología social
museos y comunidad juntos y tengo que
terminar diciendo una frase maravillosa
de un amigo muy querido que es mario
sagas él es director del museo de la
república de brasil y además presidente
del movimiento internacional para la
nueva museología y él dice que la
museología que no sirve para la vida no
sirve para nada
[Música]